Speaker 1: And another thing, by the
way, and I just thought this was so
just such a such a wonderful story.
Last week, Alex Jones came out,
did a video where he told his audience that he
was officially endorsing Florida Governor Ron.
Speaker 2: DeSantis for president.
Speaker 1: Over Donald Trump. He not only said.
That Ron DeSantis was.
Speaker 2: In Jones's words.
Speaker 1: Way better than
Trump. Way better than Trump.
His exact words. He also said that the Santos is
the kind of guy that what Trump should be like.
Again, his exact words, what Trump should be
like. That was last week. Now, earlier this week,
Alex Jones realized, oh, no, I've made a
mistake and I've made the big guy angry,
even though as far as I've seen, Donald Trump
has not issued any statements whatsoever
attacking Alex Jones for that. So I don't buy
for a second. Alex Jones is Oh no, Trump's
angry. He didn't say anything, didn't seem like he
cared. But anyway, Alex Jones comes out this week
in what's called an emergency warning.
Speaker 2: And he says this.
Speaker 1: Not a warning out of any desire
to hurt you, Mr. Trump, but to save your
important legacy and hopefully ensure you can
get back into the White House coming up in 2024.
We know the election was stolen. We know the deep
state is trying to set you up in any way they can.
We understand you are a lion surrounded by
hyenas. So this is my emergency message to you,
Mr. President, to go and actually watch the
first 30 minutes of Thursday's show so you
can see what I said in context. The corporate
media edited it down to a 32nd clip to make it
sound like I'm only for DeSantis and that I've
abandoned you. That's not true. It's the contrary.
Right now that that's totally believable. I mean,
it's not like you just got popped for $40 million
for lying. So, yes, we totally believe that the
clip we all saw with our own eyes, heard it with
our own ears, processed it with our own brains,
was totally just fabricated. The media made it up.
They deceptively edited it. No. You're on video
literally saying Ron DeSantis is way better than
Donald Trump. This is what Trump should be like.
You said that you can look into Santos's eyes.
Here it is. I don't just watch a man's actions, as
Chris said, judge a tree by its fruit. I can also
look in his eyes on HD video and I see the real
sincerity. Is that taken out of context with you
talking about how much you just love Ron DeSantis
over Donald Trump? You also said that you're no
longer going to pigheaded Lee. That's the word you
used. Support Donald Trump. But again, this little
begging for forgiveness thing for Donald Trump.
I don't buy it because Trump didn't say a word.
I don't know that Trump was mad about it. I
don't know that Trump knew it happened. You know,
we know Trump sits and watches TV all day
long, but I don't know that he's sitting there.
Speaker 2: And watching Alex Jones.
Speaker 1: So I think what happened
is that Jones realized he made a lot of his Trump
supporting audience mad. So that little emergency
warning he issued that wasn't to make Donald Trump
happy. That was to make Jones's audience happy by
trying to convince them that what he said last
week totally never happened. I am Farron Cousins
and for David Pakman you can get more from me on
YouTube at YouTube.com slash fair and balanced
and YouTube.com slash the Ring of Fire.
I'm on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram at
Fair and balanced. This is the David Pakman show.
I'm Farron Cousins in for David Pakman. And we'll.
Speaker 2: Be right.
Speaker 1: Back.